[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the columnist
cara malone and the editor of the career
david clegg welcome to both of you i
know you're with us through to just
before midnight um to the front pages
then let us start with the guardian it
leaves with threats of further
disruption from airport staff teachers
and the nhs
terminal chaos warns the metro as
british airways workers voted to strike
today
the telegraph reports on boris johnson's
push for green fuel to be relaxed which
has experts warning it could affect the
pm's net zero petrol pledge
the daily express has a european judge
criticizing the lack of transparency at
the european court of human rights
the times leads with the pm saying that
prince charles should keep an open mind
on rwanda
the career leads with nicolas sturgeon
quizzed on dundee murderer robbie
mcintosh's parole hearing
and the star has this story on household
tech product alexa
resurrecting voices
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let us return to our guests
then carol malone and david clegg
welcome to both of you um we'll talk
about the by-elections very very soon
but let's kick off with the papers most
of them leading on uh there's the strike
threat uh you know moving into other
areas carol what did you make of what
the british airways workers have decided
to do
well before i tell you that it's good to
see you i haven't seen you for months
hello
likewise very pleased to see you both as
well
yeah i mean yeah
do you know i have
much more sympathy with the airport
workers than i do with the rmt workers
you know they've been they've been
messed around you know thousands of them
were ruthlessly sacked in the middle of
the pandemic whilst the the airport and
the airlines were taking vast amounts of
cash from the government they were being
fired they were being made redundant and
and you know
the airlines are trying to get them back
now and of course many of them have
found other work they found better paid
work work that doesn't you know have 3
a.m shifts to be to be dealing with but
you know the ones that are left are
taking the brunt of the chaos and that's
really not fair now this is 100 percent
down to the airport bosses they were not
prepared for the restrictions being
lifted they didn't hire enough people
back the people that they're trying to
hire i've got to go through all sorts of
security restrictions and of course it's
taking time so this is 100 down the
bosses and the poor staff that are there
are having to deal with the abuse the
anger the frustration of of thousands
and thousands of people who are trying
to go on holiday you know this chaos has
been going on since easter they've even
had you know i think the boss of
manchester airport was actually she
resigned because of the chaos edison
because she hadn't made sufficient
preparations and it's happening all over
now
yes you you would always i suppose max
out your potential impact in your choice
of strike timing um but the the airlines
issue is fascinating isn't it david you
know there's been an accusation that all
contracts have been gone and people have
been re-employed under under new terms
um that these ba staff want their money
back when they had their wages
effectively docked in those difficult
times i guess from the airlines point of
view
they lost a lot of money you know that
money isn't there for them and it and
even now we see that actually travel is
difficult for people
i think that the travel industry is
certainly facing them in certain periods
still and i can understand why people
running
airlines would be slightly concerned
about what the future holds given the
last few years of covert however i do
think that there's a great deal of
credibility in what the gmb are saying
about their members these are these are
people who are genuinely generally low
paid the
majority of them are female and during
cuvette during that uh period of great
uncertainty for the travel industry
their pay was docked by 10
and at the time i guess that there was
some cover for that given everything
that was going on but the fact that that
is continuing now when they're being
asked to work normally and things are
recovering and i should say that the
better paid executives in these
companies pay has gone back to normal
levels that doesn't seem that doesn't
seem right to me so i do agree with
carol that there is i think a more a
great deal of sympathy uh for these
people uh and on what they're uh trying
to achieve for this strike now it is
going to cause a great deal of chaos
it's being time for the summer holidays
uh i think heathrow could be brought to
his knees because we're talking about
700 people uh and we know that british
airways has so many flights out of
heathrow every day
and that of course is going to be
layered on top of the continuing train
strike which i think we will see uh if
that if that dispute is continuing uh
i've been feeling it fairly uh heavily
this week there was
precisely zero trains from dundee to
edinburgh or glasgow today with the
strike being on so and i guess if that
if that dispute is continuing we will
see that being targeted for the school
holidays and for the summer holidays
again so it does look like this uh
industrial unrest is going to be
continuing
yes um we're going to return to that in
just a moment we've just got those
ballot boxes arriving in wakefield uh we
are keeping a very close eye obviously
on these by-elections which will be
fascinating through the night to see the
swing um you know certainly labor really
pushing as we heard there from our
correspondent in wakefield and then this
lib dem resurgence in the south uh but
as you can see they are going to verify
these votes and then start counting them
um we understand that we might get an
indication around midnight in wakefield
but i mean really
the question is whether this has any
impact on boris johnson or has he put
his those torrid times behind him carol
um well he's already said he won't quit
if uh because both of those seats but i
think it's going to be a very good
indicator of just how toxic
you know people see he is you know this
the people that matter now you know
we've had the confidence vote and mps
have been clear what they think about
boris the thing that really matters now
is what the general public thinks what
the electorate thinks and we're going to
find out that tonight i mean i was
listening to your your reports before it
is true you know the the the tories only
had something like a three and a half
thousand majority in wakefield um you
know it was it was not it's in but that
would be very indicative for all the
other red wall seats a lot of the tories
seats that they took from the red wall
were with very small majorities and if
they lose this one
the fear will be that they'll lose the
other ones um but i think even if you
know if labor win wakefield unless they
win it by more than a 5 000 majority
that's still not good for them because
that that shows that the people aren't
necessarily going to go back to labor so
i think i think it you know for both
parties tonight they'll be on ten dogs
but you know i think what this is going
to do basically this is going to start
another tory revolt if he loses both
seats and there are more people going to
be likely to be calling for him to quit
tomorrow like i said he said he won't
but you know it's it's it's just going
to stop the whole thing and go this is
going to keep happening with boris you
know it's it's you know every time
something like this happens the people
who hate him in the party his critics
are going to say he has to go he's toxic
yeah and just very quickly david there
are some big questions that might be
answered tonight and and one is were
those labor seats lent to boris johnson
only for brexit and was it a was it just
for that and secondly can the liberal
democrats be the sponge that they used
to be for dissatisfied voters which has
an impact in scotland as well i know so
you know what do you what should we take
from these by-elections
so i think the second point there is
more interesting and probably more
important about what happens with the
lib dems if labor don't win
wakefield after everything that's
happened in the last few months with the
context of a prime minister tory prime
minister who's been the first prime
minister to be found to have broken the
law on office with all the party gate
sagas and with the context of why this
by-election is is is happening for
labour not to put in a good result here
would be would be it would be a disaster
for them so that they have to win this
there's there's no doubt about that i
think it's more of an ask for the
liberal democrats to win the other seat
that will require not only uh
disaffected tories to go to the liberal
democrats but also labour voters to lend
them their vote tactically in the hope
of giving boris johnson a bloody nose i
think that seems a more difficult ask
and
if it is to happen that's when we know
that boris johnson is in real trouble
because if he was to lose both of these
seats overnight he's going to wake up
tomorrow with her with a real headache
because you could not be a tory mp with
any kind of uh slim majority and feel
confident about being re-elected with
boris johnson as your leader so i think
i think the the
the lib dems is the is the more
interesting uh question there
luckily we've got a long um period to
discuss all the newspapers at 11 isn't
it because we're running out of time i'm
just going to show you the pictures that
we were going to talk about about the
the airport strikes the possibility and
the timing of it the guardian uh airport
staff vote to strike as the threat of
disruption widens um saying that uh
according to the gmb 95 percent of those
who voted said they were prepared to
strike and that was on a turnout of more
than 80 percent that's genuinely
overwhelming and then the the metro as
well uh terminal chaos summer holidays
threat as ba strikes add to airport
mayhem
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview uh with me now the
columnist carol malone and the editor of
the courier david clegg welcome back to
both of you keeping an eye obviously on
those by-elections but in the meantime
david let's kick off with the telegraph
which is a story about
public sector pensioners not so much the
state pension do explain for us if you
can
yeah this this is an interesting little
nugget that's on the front of the
telegraph tomorrow and it's about uh
public sector pensions and how much
they're going to go up by they say that
it will be 10
which given the context of what we've
just been talking about about what
workers are getting what is seeming like
a reasonable pay rise for people we've
got some places where there's no pay
rises or just a couple of percent
the reason why this is going to happen
is related to the triple lock of the
state pension which as we know means
that the it will rise by the greatest
thing which
is going to be inflation this time round
which means that the state pension is
likely to go up by 10 in september and
the public sector pensions which are a
very uh
outlay for the government are tied to
that so they'll have to go up that as
well so it does it does give the
prospect of retired civil servants
retired teachers retired uh nhs workers
getting more extra money than their
former colleagues who are still at work
perhaps in the in the pay settlement and
given that squeeze on public finances
and the fact that there's already i
think a feeling in some quarters that uh
public sector pensions are
very uh generous in comparison to their
private sector counterparts it could be
something that becomes a source of
tension i think so it's quite a little
interesting story in the telegraph
tomorrow sorry to rush you then got uh
under a minute left and uh carol while
the pm made it to rwanda before any of
the asylum seekers that he wants to send
there uh the daily express picks up the
story about the involvement of the
european court of human rights
yeah this is an a an echr judge called
latif kuzanov and he says he's
criticizing uh
the european court saying that the name
of the judge who made the decision to
grant that that plane should be
published he's saying this is a public
decision so the judge should be named
and there were lots of lots of
speculation last week because of george
wash they thought it could be a russian
judge then they thought it'd be it could
be a hungarian judge it could have been
a judge from liechtenstein and and but
no one would tell us who it was and we
actually should know that we should know
the name of the judge who overturned the
decisions of the highest court in this
land